je suis né il ya trente ans j'envoie
quelques-uns qui se disent pour 30 ans
elle est quand même assez tapez vous
avez raison j'en ai 50 ma première date
de naissance correspond à une première
histoire d'amour celle de mes parents ma
deuxième histoire d'amour correspond à
la mienne à deuxième date de naissance
correspond à mon histoire d'amour parce
que l'amour peut être une renaissance
je me suis fiancé à 19 ans marié à 20
ans quand moi même je suis devenue mère
de famille et que j'ai vu des filles
je me suis dit que c'était complètement
foot maître marié aussitôt et j'ai
cherché à comprendre
j'ai trouvé je suis marié aussitôt parce
que j'avais besoin de pouvoir exister
j'avais besoin de pouvoir être je n'ai
pas eu une enfance malheureuse
j'avais beaucoup d'amis j'ai beaucoup ri
pas beaucoup travaillé j'avais des frère
une soeur une grande famille
j'ai vraiment manqué de rien sauf
peut-être d'une chose essentielle
j'ai manqué de pouvoir exister
en effet dans ma famille j'avais un père
qu'il savait une mère qu'il savait c'est
que son mari savait et nous savions tous
ce que mon père savait heureusement mon
père savait souvent très bien je le
crois encore je suis pas totalement
guérie vous voyez il n'empêche que vous
est-ce que j'étais moi dans cette
famille
à dix neuf ans donc je tombe amoureuse
d'un garçon qui me dit ton avis compte
des paroles vont de la valeur des idées
sont intéressantes
alors je suis grise et je fonce et nous
nous marions au tout début de notre
histoire
boosté par la sécurité affective qu'il
m'offrait je m'en bouffe avec plaisir
dans cet espace où je peux te dire je
joue je peux dire moi où je peux dire
j'aime je n'aime pas je ne veux pas je
veux je découvre que mon couple m'offre
un formidable espace de liberté pour
être moi même alors je ne vous cache pas
que notre première année de mariage ne
fut pas de tout repos
en effet j'étais comme un affamé et ça
n'a pas été facile pour mon mari qui je
vous le dis ce soir je lui dis est un
fantôme comment avons nous fait pour
tenir
en fait je crois je suis même sûr que
nous étions tous les deux animés par le
même désir le désir que notre couple
dure le désir que notre couple
s'inscrivent dans la durée
alors nous avons retroussé nos manches
et nous nous sommes attelés pour que
notre relation reste idéal la découverte
de cet espace où je pouvais être moi
même me m'épanouissais me rendais
pleinement heureuse et du coup j'avais
envie à mon tour de rendement mario
heureux je lui offrais aussi cet espace
c'était vraiment du donnant donnant mais
un donnant-donnant on n'attend pas de
recevoir pour donner nous devenions
alors tous les deux co responsable de
notre relation
coresponsable de notre bonheur
autour de nous des amis se séparé
divorcé étaient malheureux et ce qui me
rendait le plus le plus folles en fait
c'était que ses amis étaient résignés
dans leur malheur
moi qui découvrait que le couple pouvait
être un formidable espace on pouvait
être heureux
alors comment mon bonheur ne pas être
arrogant tu ne pas être indécente par
rapport à eux qui souffrait plusieurs me
prenait à témoin de leur histoire me
donner le rôle des coûts tente me donner
le rôle de conseillère donc petit à
petit une idée s'imposer si j'avais
envie que les autres découvrent ce que
moi même j'avais envie que j'avais
découvert
il fallait que j'en fasse mon métier et
me voilà devenue conseillère conjugale
alors merveilleuses années de formation
qui m'ont appris à décoder les règles de
vie nous avions mis en place avec mon
mari pour que notre couple dure
j'emploie ce terme de règles de vie
moi quand j'entends règles de vie je ne
pense pas forcément le mot vie j'entends
plutôt le mot règles et règles dans mon
esprit se sont encore comme loi car
quand efforts volonté en fait c'est pas
très sexy ça parle pas beaucoup d'amour
et pourtant en fait ce qu'il faut que
j'avoue c'est qu'au bout de ces trente
ans de vie commune et quelques années
d'expérience de mon métier on ne peut se
passer de ces règles de vie pour
inscrire notre couple dans la durée ce
sont ces règles dont je vais vous parler
ce soir
alors oui parce qu'elle est laide un
couple a duré mais surtout parce
qu'elles nous aident à faire que ce
couple devienne un espace formidable
pour être soi même
je vais vous présenter ce soir marc et
sophie j'aurais pu présenter
bertrand thiery latt ali ou martin ce
serait très politiquement correct
simplement dans mon cabinet moi je vois
essentiellement des soufis et des
marques marques à sophie sont mariés
depuis onze ans ils ont trois enfants et
c'est la troisième séance qu'ils font
avec moi mais qu'est ce que tu veux que
je fasse de plus je passe mon temps à te
rendre service ce soir encore je suis
allé chercher les enfants à l'école
marc c'est gentil d'être allé chercher
les enfants à l'école mais je ne vais
pas demander tu sais quand tu m'as en
service ça ne veut pas dire que tu
m'aimes
mais qu'est ce que tu veux plus
qu'est-ce que je peux faire marx a fait
onze ans qu'on vit ensemble on ne fait
jamais rien tous les deux à chaque fois
qu'on sort c'est avec des amis ou les
enfants ou avec la famille mais je ne
savais pas que c'est ce que tu veux ce
dont tu avais besoin
enfin marc ça paraît évident nous sommes
un couple mais non je ne suis pas dans
ta tête je ne peux pas le savoir
en fait tu as raison marque moi je les
découverts il ya pas longtemps que
j'avais besoin de ça marc et sophie
vous connaissez vous connaissez vous vos
désirs intimes vos besoins intime ses
besoins qui lorsqu'ils sont comblés ils
font qu'on se sent exister font qu'on se
sent vivre donc la première règle de vie
et non c'est ce soir devant vous c'est
apprendre à se connaître c'est vrai
comment un homme et une femme qui vivent
ensemble peuvent apprendre à se
connaître à se comprendre
s'ils ne partagent pas ce qu'ils ont de
plus profond s'ils ne partagent pas ce
qu'ils vivent leur fragilité leur force
très souvent au début de notre histoire
d'amour quand on se rencontre on se
parle on se raconte pendant des heures
on se confie pendant des heures mais
notre histoire personnelle elle ne
s'arrête pas à la rencontre les
événements de la vie continue de nous
faire évoluer continue nous faire réagir
nous faire prendre position ces
événements nous font devenir
malheureusement souvent et même bien
après des années de mariage la peur de
déplaire
la peur de se dévoiler la peur
d'entendre ou de dire des choses qui
risquerait de nous déranger le manque de
curiosité de l'un vis-à-vis de l'autre
font qu'on a du mal à aller vers cet
autre les événements de la vie aussi
nous renvoie bien souvent à notre passé
comment un homme et une femme qui vivent
ensemble pour se comprendre et se
connaître ne réaliste il pas les
répercussions de la vie de l'enfant qui
l'ont été sur la vie de l'adul qu'ils
sont maintenant font-ils le lien entre
le trait de caractère qui les anime et c
est leur histoire d'enfant c'est pas
toujours facile de faire ces liens on en
n'a pas toujours envie parce que c'est
parfois douloureux
et pourtant
si marc regarder le monde depuis la
fenêtre de sophie si sophie regardait le
monde depuis la fenêtre de marque
il pourrait aller à la rencontre l'un de
l'autre en se parlant en se racontant
mettant des mots sur leurs histoires sur
leur histoire personnelle
il réalise -s'il conscientisent rey
leurs blessures d'enfants
c'est là qu'on peut dire que l'amour est
un facteur de résilience si marc et
sophie se connaissent et se comprenait
il se ferait confiance et il y aurait
entre eux une sécurité affective qui
leur permettraient et qu'il a qui les
aiderait à guérir ses blessures
d'enfance
écoutez entouraient voire même console
et il deviendrait alors d être libéré du
poids de leurs blessures
mais comment marc et sophie peuvent-ils
y aller à la rencontre l'un de l'autre
tu ses marques ces moments tous les deux
j'en aurais vraiment besoin parce que au
moins on pourrait parler
le problème je pense et quelques mois
qu'ils parleraient à ça c'est sûr
ya que toi qui parlerait parce que de
toute façon quand je parle tu me dis que
ce que je dis est nu que je ne comprends
pas que ce n'est pas intéressant
il ne peut pas y avoir de discussion
entre nous je n'ai pas le droit de ne
pas être d'accord avec toi vous mémoire
marque
au moins on ne peut pas dire que je ne
communique pas ah le voilà le fameux mot
lorsqu'on parle du couple la
communication et la deuxième règle
apprendre à communiquer
alors vous serez d'accord avec moi nous
vivons dans un monde d'hyper
communication cependant moi les coupes
que je reçoit en entretien sont des
couples qui vivent un véritable déficit
de communication et ça entraîne chez eux
un terrible sentiment de solitude les
plus de partage plus de complicité et
chacun vit l'un à côté de l'autre avec
ses frustrations ses rancunes ces
questions en fait on est comme deux bus
qui flottent l'un à côté de l'autre
elles sont un peu cabossée ces bulles
elles sont pas très très belle
on n'a pas envie de les éclaté parce que
on ne sait pas ce que cela déclencherait
vivre à 2 et se sentir seul c'est quand
même un comble pas un article dans les
journaux sur le couple sans que le mot
de communication apparaissent il est
employé à toutes les sauces
or ce que je constate dans ma pratique
c'est que très souvent ce mot de
communication il se confond avec le mot
jugement reproche exigences de toute
façon je ne dis plus rien parce que
chaque fois que je parle je me fais
engueuler marque
voilà un un beau mécanisme de défense
on l'appelle la fuite alors marc à
raison de fuir le conflit si cela lui
est désagréable seulement lorsque la
crise sera terminée il faudra bien
qu'ils aient une résolution de ce
conflit
mais souvent la peur nous empêche de
résoudre ses conflits
la peur de repartir au combat la peur de
revivre une crise de revivre une tension
de revivre la violence des mots de
revivre parfois la violence des gestes
quand il ya communication quand il ya
conflit
c'est vraiment extrêmement important
qu'il puisse y avoir une communication
parce que sinon c'est une véritable
bombe à retardement
mais ce soir
de quelle communication parlons nous la
communication c'est une mise en commun
qui part de notre centre vital de notre
centre de l'île de notre existence c'est
pour ça que c'est très important de se
connaître soi même il ne peut y avoir de
communication dans un couple sans qu'il
y ait dialogue un dialogue qui nous
permet un discours entre nous où je te
donne tu es l'information pour que tu me
communiquent toi ton information
il ne peut y avoir dialogue non plus
ceux qui les écoutent
je t'entends je t'écoute
sauf si tu me parles en reproches marc
et sophie s'il se faisait confiance
pourrait s'offrir cet espace où ils
pourraient exprimer ce qu'ils ressentent
ce qu'ils vivent ou et ils pourraient
exprimer ce qu'ils sont à partir de leur
centre parce que le couple même dans un
conflit est un formidable espace de
liberté pour être soi même
alors marc et sophie repartent en ayant
compris qu'il fallait qu'ils apprennent
à mieux se connaître qu'il fallait
qu'ils apprennent à mieux communiquer
mais ils reviennent me voir quinze jours
plus tard je sens bien sophie que tu
n'es pas fier de moi tu ne me parles
jamais de mon travail
tu ne me dis jamais que ce que je fais
bien ma famille tu la trouves nu moi
aussi je me trouve nul avec toi
d'ailleurs en fait je ne sais pas
pourquoi nous nous sommes mariés nous
venons de demande tellement différent
mais comment peux tu dire sa marque
quand je te parles de ton travail tu me
dis je ne comprendrais pas que ce n'est
pas intéressant que c'est trop compliqué
à expliquer ta famille c'est toi qu'il
veut plus la voir
et moi je passe mon temps à te dire que
tu es un bon père qu'est ce que tu veux
que je fasse de plus marc quel est ce
sentiment de dévalorisation et dans quel
rôle vous êtes vous installé tous les
deux alan voilà que ce point de la
troisième règle de vie trouver la juste
place dans son couple et sortir de la
dépendance affective
en entendant marc et sophie on comprend
qu'ils se sont installés tous les deux
dans des rôles dans lesquels ils ne sont
pas bien ne sont pas à l'aise dans ce
rôle dans leur histoire de couple sophie
a pris le rôle du dominant marque a pris
le rôle du dominé ils ont pas forcément
choisit ses rôles il se les ont peut
être distribué de façon totalement
inconsciente marque ci est tombé dans la
dépendance affective dans le piège de la
dépendance affective il un tel besoin de
reconnaissance
un tel besoin d'amour mais ce besoin
n'est pas clarifiée sophie essaie d'y
répondre tant bien que mal mais et les
répond mal la dépendance affective de
marque au début de leur histoire avec
sophie était très gratifiante pour elle
le maintenant elle devient étouffante
elle ne l elle envahit soufi et sophie 1
1 c'est d'être obligé de lui prouver son
amour le ppe-de estime de marque
le pôle estime de mme demarcq que marc a
pour lui pardon fait qu' il ne peut
vivre ce qu'il doit vivre selon ses
propres choix selon ses propres
sentiments il ne peut être seule sa
demande affective est insatiable
c'est un puits sans fond
l'espace vital de sophie est envahi l
étouffe elle va fuir la racine de cette
dépendance affective ou alors d'une trop
grande distance qui peut s'installer
entre dans un couple est vraiment
profondément planté dans la terre de
notre enfance alors maintenant nous
allons de laisser marc et sophie qui
vont cheminer pendant quelques séances
encore avec moi ils montrent ils vont
apprendre à ne pas rester seul et à ne
pas avoir peur ne pas rester seul avec
mon mari nous ne sommes jamais rester
seul
nous nous sommes toujours entouré d'amis
qui nous font du bien
d'amis en fait qu'ils ont ce même désir
cette même recherche que leur couple
s'installe dans la durée
parce que nous savons que rien n'est
jamais gagné en conclusion je vous
dirais que rien n'est jamais acquis mais
ça vous le savez déjà
j'espère que nous allons encore avoir
plusieurs années à vivre avec mon mari
avec des événements heureux des
événements malheureux
serons-nous les vivres serons nous en
faire des forces nous ne sommes sûrs de
rien la seule chose dont nous sommes
sûrs c'est que ces trente années de vie
commune ont été des années
d'épanouissement personnel
extraordinaire et j'espère que les 50 60
70 années qui nous reste à vivre
ensemble nous allons continuer à
apprendre à nous connaître pour mieux
nous comprendre
continuez toujours à apprendre à mieux
communiquer pour garder ce lien à
prendre toujours à occuper la bonne
place pour nous respecter
ce soir je voudrais adresser un grand
merci à marc et elle se fit et à tant
d'autres couples qui sont venus me voir
parce que ce sont de véritables booster
d'amour pour moi comment ne pas être
touché
comment ne pas être ému par ces pardons
qu'il se donne lorsqu'il réalise le mal
qu'ils se sont fait à mon tour c'est
pardon je les reçois et je les donne un
peu plus facilement grâce à eux ce soir
tête vous invite à fêter le couple à
fêter l'amour
alors moi je voudrais vous inviter si
vous êtes en couple ou pas à regarder
l'homme ou la femme qui est à côté de
vous à vous regardez vous à lui prendre
la main et lui dire avec moi va vis et
deviens